the Joe Rogan experience on one hand
when you have children and you bring a
child to the zoo on one hand it's really
fascinating to watch this little person
look at all these different animals and
and and freak out and and and see how
amazing it is but that's the only pro is
introducing human beings like little
human beings in particular to these
animals everything else is a con except
for the animals that are like really
endangered and they protect them and
help breed them and then sometimes they
were responsible for some reintroduction
efforts but other than that it's an
animal prison weird I don't take the
position or I do I don't know Matt this
person that's trying to represent an
ideology necessarily I'm not against all
zoos but I have to say that there's
nothing more sad than seeing elephants
cats bears I mean cats man the cats when
they're pacing back and forth I mean
just get them out of there whoo-hoo sir
whose purpose are you serving is that
good for you I mean seeing an animal
that's got Zucco sasai mean it's it's
it's it's a mental case and we don't
know what the [ __ ] going on in their
head so we have no idea that most people
just watch and think this is just maybe
normal or something right a lot of
people we're not see because the veil is
only now sort of coming off and people
are started now getting the truth on the
matters you start to see things for what
they are I watched the video on YouTube
some weeks ago and it was Marineland in
the 70s and man was this place busy and
the people were just I mean they were
they were climbing over each other to be
next to the pool I've never seen
anything like I worked at 12 years I've
never seen the amount of people that
this thing had and we looked into pool
there's a bull Orca who's he spans the
literal length of the pool that he's in
on the side with his there's dorsal fin
over and he's literally staring at the
wall not moving and then you got two
other massive orcas that are in this
pool like maybe five times the size of
this room kind of thing and people are
celebrating like it's and the view the
video has like this sort of quirky music
and it's kind of funny and fun and I'm
watching this going what a disconnect of
time like where this you're looking at
exactly what you see today in terms of
the animals and the conditions that
they're in yet here these people having
knowing nothing about it just in awe the
beauty the met the majesty of these
animals is the majestic nature of these
animals and yet we couldn't see for
ourselves whatsoever how abusive
and gross this was it's it was really a
weird and strange thing but that's the
old marine lands a legacy business they
built they built themselves on on having
people come and experience the shock and
awe of these animals and they did very
very well but that time is long gone now
long gone I think we're gonna come to a
time in the future where people think
the same way about zoos I think it's
we're just we're gonna realize like I
get that you want to see them I get it I
get you want to see them I get i-i'll on
I want to see them too but god damn we
got to stop doing that like this is no
way also for you that the problem is
humans don't have any real experience
with animals we have experience with
dogs and cats which are these
domesticated weird little fluffy friends
they are not animals we don't have much
experience with real animals and even
the animals that you have experience
with they're urbanized you know like
pigeons that you can feed or squirrels
that take peanuts from you you can out
into the world in the the world of the
wild of forests and mountains and you
you see actual real animals and it's
almost psychedelic there's like a weird
like paradigm shift that goes through
when you see a wild animal in the in the
actual like oh this is where it's
supposed to be it kind of feels because
you're in their world you can be that
because I feel like oh what because the
series of tools that that animal has in
its world that doesn't translate in
captivity for instances like wait a
second that thing can spring on me climb
on that like like I'm in its world now
it's to me that's the AH of the
experience of witnessing animals because
since the year and a half that expired
that that from our last show you know I
had the blessed the gift of seeing
dolphins in the wild I went down to I
can't remember what beach it was but it
was while I was in California and that
was my first experience in fact again
I'm from a small place and then this
year I was able to go to Washington
State and see orcas in the wild now I've
jumped off orcas rostrums into the air
so high that you're looking down into
Dixie cup
that's pretty awesome but there's
nothing like having seen [ __ ] bull
Orca with an eight-foot mass on his back
swimming next to his mother and all the
never my heart sunk into my stomach I'd
never seen anything more majestic Wow
Wow
[Applause]